irréversible ou un parfum de scandale
sur la croisette le film de gaspar noé
projeté ce soir en compétition
officielle arrive à cannes précédé d'une
réputation sulfureuse le film choc de la
quinzaine interprété par le couple
monica bellucci et vincent cassel sort
aujourd'hui dans les salles avec une
interdiction aux moins de 16 ans sabine
gorny olivier diète
voici ceux par qui le scandale est
arrivé
prenez un couple d'acteurs à la mode
amoureux dans la vie comme à l'écran un
réalisateur sulfureux un peu trash
gaspar noé
une histoire qui tient en trois lignes
il sait mais les violer il avance pour
faire chic film est l'histoire à
l'envers avec une caméra qu'elle tourne
il servait tout chaud sur la croisette
et vous obtenez la une des gazettes
c'est plus en prend plein la gueule
c'est un film qui est lamentable
insoutenable
vraiment de la merde c'est un vrai film
de cinéma s'ils sont la forme est
extrêmement aboutie qui bouleverse
profondément comptait jouer le film de
gaspar noé est en compétition à minuit
et en soit ça dit que c'est un objet
singulier régulier on est prêts cet
assaut de violence gratuite et une scène
d'une extrême sauvagerie monica bellucci
viol est massacrée par un pervers
sanguinaire un plan séquence de 20
minutes interminables quasiment
insoutenable
[Musique]
il est physique avantageux avec les jeux
avec la notion de calibre de spectateurs
et c'est quand on fait des films
il faut s'amuser à faire des choses
qu'on n'a pas vu mon cardiologue il m'a
dit d'arrêter il m'a dit faut arrêter
foire est aisé de mourir c est nouveau
c'est son orgasme provocateur nourrisson
descend juste un peu voyeur et fasciné
par la marginalité et si monica accepté
sans réserve les scènes les plus
sordides
c'est qu'elle y avait autre chose que
des images chocs qu'un cinéma racoleur
les termes de la dualité de l'homme les
mâles elle est bien qu'il y à nous bien
sûr on n'a pas enlevé des voix requis
fin les monstres qui nous habite
ok monica mais ne nous mentons pas
horrifiée ou fasciné comme la caméra le
spectateur est amoureux de vous avant
tout est votre partenaire à vrai dire un
peu jaloux
je suis vraiment content d'un viol parce
que ça m'embête c'est le but que je
marque et d'en manger votre actrice en
pierre autant faire avec
alors succès on avait au public dès ce
soir de décider irréversible a d'ores et
déjà gagné son pari faire parler
[Applaudissements]